You're still here?
It's over.
Go home.
Oh, you're expecting a little tease for Deadpool 2.
Well, we don't have that kind of money.
Spend it all on the suit.
Go.
Oh!
But I can tell you one thing.
(Whispers) Come here.
Okay.
Cable is gonna be in the sequel.
Yeah.
Cable, he's like one of my favorite characters in the whole wide world. (Thump)
I love the guy.
Just need a big guy with a flat top.
I'm thinking: Dolph Lundgren, Newt Gingrich,
Grace Jones, Keira Knightley. Could be anybody.
(Whispers) Go, go, go, go.
(Deadpool voice-over) 600lbs. of Chimichangas.
4 pairs of assless chaps.
12 humiliating minutes on a casting couch.
117 script pages.
465 ad libs.
(Deadpool) What the shit!
(Deadpool Voice-over) 2 nerds.
7 magical Unicorns.
3 good walls
and a fourth that's broken.
(Deadpool) Did I leave the stove on?
(Deadpool Voice-over) 42 rejection letters from Fox.
1 leaked video.
783 million fans.
For your consideration.
(Fake laugh)
(Deadpool) Fake laugh. Hiding real pain.
(Deadpool Voice-over) Deadpool.